[Music]
david
is on the line in chicago hi david
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey anthony thanks for taking
my call sure how can we help
uh i'm looking to make a luxury purchase
and i've been eyeing this purchase for a
very long time
and i finally got a fool from my wife
and
she's on board now and now i just want
your input to see if it's justified
financially for us
uh it's a luxury car that i'm looking to
buy
what kind of car is it it's a 2017
uh rolls-royce two-door
okay what's it cost it's 220 000
how much um 220 000. 220 000.
okay what do you mean what do you make
of here
uh combined meaning by what we make 550
000
okay and what's your net worth um
we have about 2.4 million dollars and
that includes some of our house too okay
and then two million dollars in the
mutual funds
so your net worth is well 2.5
oh 2.5 okay yeah and and we do have
about uh
our house is worth 750 000 but we still
have uh
300 000 remaining on the mortgage
hmm okay any other debt
i just had to have you shouldn't but i
just got to ask a question
no other debt okay okay uh
well the rule of thumb is you shouldn't
have uh items that are going
cars items or things with motors in them
that total up more than half your annual
income
this is close and
obviously these numbers are are
ridiculous for most people they don't
face a half million dollar income and
they don't face a 200 000 car purchase
um i um
i wouldn't do until i paid off my house
if i were in your shoes
um okay but i i don't think i don't
think the car is completely ridiculous
yeah uh it's uh it's close
i mean it's kind of on the bubble uh you
how much money have you got in savings
not counting returns savings we have
about
200 000 okay and you don't have any
money other than
that that's non-retirement money have
investments that are non-retirement
i just don't host yeah but do you you
don't have a
a non-retirement mutual fund or stock
portfolio or something like that
no no so if you go buy this 200 000
car you got no money yeah you have no
more cash right no emergency fund
it would just be the 200 000 yeah like
yeah you would have no
you'd have no emergency fund if you
bought the car
you mean uh oh okay no no yeah so no
no you don't buy the car yeah no the bus
this car is not an emergency
so out of the 200 000 you have in
savings if i were in your
shoes what would i do i think you need
to get this car
someday yeah but i don't think you can
get it now
um and i don't mind i mean i think
you're probably going to end up making
more money and saving more money you've
done a great job you have a fabulous net
worth
uh but driving that car and having zero
money in the bank is unwise
right so i want an emergency fund
sitting there three to six months of
expenses
that sounds like 50 to 75 grand which
leaves you 100 and a quarter throw at
your house i'd knock my house out this
year
be done with it and then i'd save up and
pay cash for this car
next year yep that's about i said you
can do that next year we should still
also
pay off the mortgage yeah i want to pay
off the mortgage and have an emergency
fund in place
and um because here's what it amounts to
david okay
this is a toy yeah right
i've got some toys i own several
automobiles i love cars too i'm a car
guy
so i'm kind of salivating over this
purchase with you i think it's a very
cool car
that you're talking about but you you
want toys to be
where you don't financially notice them
like if i just set fire to that much
money in my driveway
would i still be okay the next morning
that's what i mean by not financially
noticing it
and if you set fire to 200 000 in your
financial situation
sitting in your driveway you would
notice it because you'd have no
emergency fund
and you still have a mortgage
and that's what that's what that's how
my thinking works and so
we work with a lot of uh uber high-end
earners some of them
uh well-known people some of them not uh
some of them athletes or music people or
whatever
and uh sometimes people have trouble
enjoying their money
and then sometimes all they do is enjoy
their money
and so uh but like i was with a guy the
other day that was
he made 15 million dollars last year
income
and he bought a four hundred thousand
dollar car
now that scene that he can set fire to
that much in his driveway
and not notice when you make 15 million
you can buy 400
000 right and so but you're you're not
quite
at that mark yet and i want to get you
there to where because
let me tell you what it'll do from
someone who's done it okay
it will increase your enjoyment of the
purchase
when it is not it putting
anything at risk yeah when it's it's
when it doesn't even show up on the
emotional bubble
it will increase your enjoyment i love
that i can't wait for that day
well you are enjoying it you've got a
lot of you've done some nice things
you've been on some nice trips you've
done
you know you've been making a great
income and so you've had the same thing
it's just
what what makes it hard to process these
things are the emotions
because when you start you know because
you start going 200 thousand are coming
you can't
who needs that 200 000 that's what
starts going through your head
well i know i don't need it but i don't
know but i want it but you know and some
of the other stuff you and i do
other people do is um you know it's just
a zero
oh yeah it's all it's just a decimal
point in zero so but
what you want is you want ratios on
items that are not producing wealth
to be small yes and then you could enjoy
them
yeah i know you're absolutely right dave
i mean when i went and purchased my
my first dream car here a few months ago
um
it felt so good to walk in there pay
cash leave
and not think about did i make the right
decision yeah like i wasn't stressed i
still had a large savings account i was
still
i mean it was it just felt so good to do
and that's a dadgum nice car yes sir
that you're driving it's me
nice car it's so beautiful and so uh
wasn't
wasn't a cheap car no sir it wasn't but
you're in a position that you could do
that and it didn't
it didn't cause your stomach to get
tight didn't cause your throat to get
tight
not at all you know or or it and it
shouldn't you know and so the
that's the the measure it's not of a
there is no amount of
car that is immoral yes there is no
amount of car that is moral
there is no amount of car that makes you
unspiritual
and that god doesn't love you because
you bought an expensive car
that that's that does not exist yes
um but there is a there but but what
indicates whether you're off or not
is have you put yourself in a position
you cannot be outrageously generous
have you put yourself in a position that
you're you're living on the line
you're right on razor's edge yes then
that's
that's unwise and if done in an extreme
you put your family at risk that is
immoral
those that don't take care of their own
household first are worse than the
unbeliever
so uh you know and so but but and some
of you are out there judging everybody
else's stuff some of you judging him
right now
and you need to get back to mind in your
own business this is the dave ramsey
show